[Music]
hey everyone i am joined by the stars
and director of marvel studios shanghai
and the legend of the 10 rings hey
everyone
all right let's get started so what is
important to your characters at the
beginning of the film when we're
introduced to the adult version of
shanxi in the movie first of all he's
going by sean
he's parking cars at the fairmont hotel
in san francisco along with his best
friend katie there's a sense that he's
kind of like a little directionless in
life shangchi is a
young man who has been running from the
pain that he really doesn't want to deal
with and i think he hides it and covers
it up with his charm and humor in the
end of our first act of our movie all of
that kind of gets exposed well the
beginning of the film i think i think
the good times are very important to
katie but i think that you know that's
telling of something a little bit deeper
which is that she doesn't really know
what she's supposed to be doing right
now xiaoling she is so complex she has
the tough and unapproachable exterior
but she also has the sensitive and
vulnerable part inside of her she's like
a flower which can survive the coldest
winter to
accomplish the mission that his
leader and also stepfather van vu gave
him so everything that he does is to try
to prove himself to him and make him
proud well this might be tough but if
you had to describe your character in
one word what would it be
self-discovery
blind trust ooh
heartfelt
oh very good answers now there is some
amazing action in this film so what was
your favorite stunt to film one of my
favorite stunts that i did was like
falling backwards off a pole it felt
like a ride like one of those slingshot
rides where like a
well hopefully a bird doesn't come
towards the end of the bus sequence
there's a scene where changshi is
basically on my back
pushing with his feet on the wall
pushing me down
that whole sequence i mean he was
actually
seeing who was actually on my back oh
my favorite stunt memory the very first
fight scene i did with semu i did punch
him in the face that's why i love it
i didn't have any martial arts
background and even though we practiced
for a thousand times i was still nervous
but simu he encouraged me and he said
it's okay it's fine just go for it you
can't hurt me
so well i just got into my character and
i just punched him in the face and the
audience can see it in a film really it
was an accident i didn't mean to but
it felt good well hey for me
commitment that's what counts right
so
now there are so many incredible moments
in this film but what are you most
excited for fans to see the action in
this movie is really unique there's
action sequences that you can describe
as beautiful and elegant and emotional
and those are adjectives i typically am
not able to use to describe an action
movie i'm most excited for them to
first of all have fun in in back in the
theater and also to see things that
maybe they recognize in their own selves
or their own lives and if they don't
it's a cool glimpse of this other world
i'm so excited for fans to be able to
see our incredible action sequences
we've got so so many in this movie and
the way i think of it it's almost like
an album and it's a good band so
not every song sounds exactly the same
you know some are really fast paced and
frenetic and chaotic and some are very
slow and some are almost like love songs
in a way and i just think it all blends
together in this perfect experience and
hopefully that's what audiences will get
when they when they watch our movie well
thank you all so much for joining me was
an absolute pleasure and all of you out
there don't miss marvel studios shang
chi and the legend of the 10 rings in
theaters september 3rd
you